[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم الى نشره الرابعه من الرياضه
التي نقدم من خلالها ابرز اخبار وملفات
السعوديه والخليج وهذه ابرز عناوين اليوم
عشيه الذكرى الاولى للحرب تجدد المعارك في
خرسون وموسكو وتستبعد خيار التسويه
مشاريع لتطوير التعليم في 29 دوله اسلاميه
المستفيدون بالالاف طلابا ومعلمين ومنشات
وفي ملفاتنا المتنوعه في الرابعه تتابعون
ايضا
[موسيقى]
الازياء التقليديه تزين احتفالات التاسيس
في السعوديه تساؤلات حول رحلتها عبر
الاجيال
وتخريج لمئتين وتسعه وسبعين جنديه سعوديه
في المديريه العامه للجوازات تمكين مستمر
للنساء في القطاع الامني
اهلا بكم نبدا من تطورات الحرب الاوكرانيه
حيث حملت الخارجيه الروسيه اوكرانيا
والدول الغربيه مسؤوليه فشل التسويه
والوصول الى نهايه للحرب في اوكرانيا وقال
نائب وزير الخارجيه الروسيه ميخائيل
جالوزين في مقابله مع وكاله تاس ان
احتمالات التوصل الى التسويه لا تزال
بعيده بالنظر الى تصريحات زيلينسكي التي
تعبر عن عزله كامله عن الحقائق بحسب
تعبيره واضاف جالوزين ان الحوار مع
زيلينسكي صعب لاعتماده المطلق على الغرب
الذي منع بدوره اي مفاوضات جوهريه ذات
معنى وشدد النائب وزير الخارجيه الروسي
على ضروره اعتراف كياف والدول الغربيه
بالواقع الجيوسياسي الحالي والاعتراف
بالمناطق الروسيه الجديده والقاء السلاح
كشرط للعوده الى طاوله المفاوته
في سياق ذي الصله حضرت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه من ان السلطات كياف تعد للقيام
باستفزاز مسلح قريبا يستهدف جمهوريه
ترانزيستيا الانفصاليه ستنفذه وحدات من
الجيش الاوكراني وقالت الدفاع الروسيه في
بيان ان اوكرانيا تزعم ان هجوم الروسيا
مزعوما قد ينطلق من اراضي هذا الهجوم
المزعوم سيكون ذريعه للعدوان الاوكراني
اكدت وزاره الدفاع البريطانيه انه على
مدار اليومين الماضيين استمر القتال
العنيف في قطاع بخموت وابقت القوات
الاوكرانيه طرق اعاده الامداد مفتوحه الى
الغرب على الرغم من الحصار الروسي والى
الجنوب تعرضت بلده فوهليدار مره اخرى لقصف
عنيف وتوقعت الدفاع البريطانيه استعداد
روسيا لمحاوله هجوميه اخرى في المنطقه رغم
هجماتها السابقه التي بائت بالفشل واضافت
انه من المحتمل ان المجموعه الشرقيه
للقوات الروسيه لا تزال مسؤوله عن عمليه
فول هيدارا مؤكده انه من غير المرجح ان
يكون لدى قائد المجموعه رستم مرادف قوه
ضاربه قادره على تحقيق اختراقه
فيما يخص الصراع المستجد بين قائد مجموعه
فاجنر والجيش الروسي يبدو ان الامور تتجه
للتهدئه حيث اعلن رئيس مجموعه فاجنر
يفخيني بريكوجين ان امدادات اضافيه من
الذخيره وصلت الى قوته في الجبهه واكد
قائد فاجنر في بيان على تيليجرام عمليه
شحن الذخيره بدات وتم بالفعل التوقيع على
الوثائق الرئيسيه المرتبطه بالعمليه مع
الجيش مضيفا بان الكره تتدحرج الان على حد
وصفه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بك احمد يعني ضعنا في جديد التطورات
الميدانيه حيث تتواجد انتوا في عموم
المعارك تحديدا التي تحدث في الشرق
نعم اهلا راويه يعني قبل قليل كان هناك
عده رشقات صاروخيه استهدفت مدينه كوبينس
في خاركيف السلطات الاقليميه او المحليه
هناك تقول ان هذا القصف استهدف البنيه
التحتيه واصفر عن عصابه بعض الاشخاص ايضا
الهجمات والمعارك على اشدها في بخموت
مجموعه وكذلك ايضا الجيش الروسي وكذلك من
الناحيه الاخرى الجيش الاوكراني هناك
معارك يعني حرب شوارع تدور في انحاء
مختلفه من المدينه القوات الروسيه تريد
السيطره باي طريقه ممكنه على هذه المدينه
في اسرع وقت ممكن كذلك ايضا هناك تعزيزات
تحاول الوصول او تحاول القاده العسكريه
الاوكرانيه ايصالها الى الجنود الاوكران
في هذه المنطقه
هذه التعزيزات هي هامه للغايه الجيش
الاوكراني يقول ان طريق التعزيزات مازال
مفتوحا حتى الان لكن يعني وفقا لما نسمعه
من
القياده العسكريه هنا ان شيئا قويا سيحدث
خلال الايام القادمه لكن جدير بالذكر
راويه ان اقوى يعني القوات الاوكرانيه
المقاتله واكثرها خبره هي التي تقاتل في
الجانب الشرقي في مخموت وكذلك في دنيتك
وكذلك ايضا في خاركيف
التي نتحدث منها الان يعني كما تشاهدين من
خلفي هناك دمار كبير اصاب هذه المدينه
هناك اكبر المقابر الجماعيه موجوده في هذه
المدينه قتل اكثر من 2000 مواطن مدني بعد
ان قامت القوات الروسيه باحتلال هذه
المدينه لمده سبعه اشهر متواصله نجحت على
اثرها بعد ذلك
القوات الاوكرانيه في دحر القوات الروسيه
وسترى مره اخرى على المدينه حتى ان الرئيس
الاوكراني زينسكي بنفسه
قام برفع العالم الاوكراني مره اخرى على
هذه المدينه واحد اشهر مباني المدينه بصفه
عامه يمكن القول ان المعاليك تبقى مستمره
بصوره كبيره وقويه خاصه في المنطقه او
مناطق والجبهات الشرقيه المسيرات
الاوكرانيه تقول القياده العسكريه انها
تحاول استهداف تجمعات عسكريه روسيه في
اكثر من منطقه وكل يتحدث ثوان الجانب
الروسي او الجانب الاوكرانيه يتحدث عن
وقوع قتل في الجانب الاخر وان الامور تسير
في صالحه يعني حبذا لو تتحرك الكاميرا ان
كانت هناك امكانيه حيث تتواجد نشاهد دمار
كبيرا حدثنا عن مظاهر الحياه في هذه
المنطقه في ايزيوم التي يمكن الكاميرا ان
تتحرك نعم نعم وكيف يستذكر الاوكران من
خلال حديثك معهم هذا هذه الذكرى الاولى
للعام يعني نحن عشيه مرور عام على هذه
الحرب
نعم يعني الاوكران هنا او المواطنون في
ايزوم يعني مرعوبون للغايه مما سيحدث خاصه
انه معنا لاكثر من سبعه اشهر كامله من هذه
الحرب التي اسفلت كما ذكرت لك عن احد اكبر
المقابر الجماعيه موجوده في هذه
المدينه
اكثر من الفيقتين قتلوا قتيل الماده
لنتحدث عن المدنيين فقط وتدمير هائل
للبناء التحتيه في هذه المدينه وكذلك
الكثير من البيوت والمحال التجاريه انا
اتحدث مع زملائي لا يوجد مكان مطاعم
مفتوحه لا يوجد
مقاهي لا يوجد اي شيء الكثير من المواطنين
غادروا المدينه بصوره كبيره لكن تخوف
الاكبر انه مع الربيع ومع اقتراب الربيع
هناك حديث بصوره كبيره ان الجنود روسيا
يعودون مره اخرى للسلاح على هذه المدينه
الهامه خاصه انه قبل فتره او وقت الحرب
قام القوات الاوكرانيه بتدمير العديد من
الجسور لتمنع وصول امدادات للقوات الروسيه
التي كانت موجوده في هذه
المدينه لذلك هنا هناك حد خوف شديد من
الحديد بصوره مستمره عن عندما تتحدث
القوات الروسيه والجانب الروسي عن ان
اوكرانيا قد تقوم بشن هجوم على الجانب
الروسي ومناطق الانفصاليه هم يرون هنا
انها ذلك ذريعه لكي تقوم لكي يقوم القوات
الروسيه مره اخرى باحتلال هذه المدينه
التي عانت بصوره كبيره كما ذكرت لك النظره
لاهميه هذه المدينه الرئيس الاوكراني
بنفسه قام باعاده رفع العالم الاوكراني
عليها مره اخرى
بالطبع هؤلاء المواطنين قات لهم ولا
الجمال في هذه الحرب متخوفون مما سيحدث
ولا يملكون اي شيء سوى الدعاء على الامور
تسير الى الافضل مع اوكرانيا نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك احمد من ايزيوم في اوكرانيا
وخلال احتفالات يوم المدافع عن الوطن تعهد
الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بتعزيز
الثالوث النووي لروسيا في اشاره منه الى
قوه عسكريه قادره على اطلاق ثلاثه انواع
من الاسلحه النوويه بوتين اكد مواصله
روسيا انتاج انظمه كنجال التي تفوق سرعتها
سرعه الصوت والبدء بنشر صواريخ زيركون
التي تطلق من البحر
كما كان الوضع من قبل سوف نل اهتماما
متزايدا لتقويه الثالث النووي وسنواصل
الانتاج الضخم لانظمه الكنجال الجويه التي
تفوق سرعتها سرعه الصوت ومن البحر سنبدا
في الامداد بكميات كبيره من صواريخ سيركون
في غضون ذلك كشفت ان اداره رئيس الامريكي
جو بايدن تدرس نشر معلومات استخباراتيه
تفيد بان الصين تخطط لتقديم اسلحه الى
روسيا من اجل دعم حربها في اوكرانيا
واشارت الى انه في الاسابيع الاخيره حصلت
دول غربيه على معلومات استخباراتيه تفيد
بان بيكين قد تنهي قيودها السابقه التي
فرضتها على امدادات الاسلحه الى روسيا
الخارجيه الصينيه ردت بالقول ان التقارير
حول عزم بكين ارسال اسلحه لروسيا مجرد
تخمينات وحمله حمله تشويه
نشره الرابعه مستمره وتتابعون فيها بعد
قليل الطيران المدني العماني يؤكد التزامه
بمعاهده شيكاغو لا تمييز بين الطائرات
المدنيه وقل للمعاهده
اهلا بكم من جديد اصدرت المحكمه الاقليميه
في برلين حكما يقضي بالسجن مدى الحياه على
السوري الفلسطيني موفق الملقب بجزار يرموك
المتهمي باطلاقه قذيفه على تجمع مدنيين
عام 2014 اثناء استلامهم سللا غذائيه من
الاونروا في مخيم اليرموك بدمشق ما ادى
الى مقتل سبعه اشخاص واصابه 30 شخصا ووجهت
اتهامات للمتهم بارتكابه جرائم ضد
الانسانيه بسبب مشاركته في الحصار على
مخيم اليرموك في دمشق
ومن برلين تنضم الينا مراسله العربيه
راغده بهنام اهلا بك راغده يعني هل هنالك
من تفاصيل اكثر حول هذه المحاكمه التي
خرجت بالحكم على الجزر كما يلقب بالسجن
مدى الحياه
اهلا بك يعني بالفعل صدر هذا الحكم يعني
السجن مدى الحياه وهو حكم حكم مشدد بمعنى
انه لن يحق له ان يطلب طلب مراجعه هذا
الحكم واخلاق سبيل بعد 15 عاما بل بعد 20
عاما يعني عليه ان يقضي عشرين عاما في
السجن قبل ان يمكنه ان يطلب طلب اخلاء
سبيل من المحكمه لانه المؤبد في المانيا
يعني ليس مؤبد مدى الحياه ولكن يسمح
للسجين بان يطلب اخلاء سبيل بعد 20 عام
وهذا الحكم هو في الواقع اقصى من الحكم
الذي انزل بانور رسلان الضابط السوري الذي
صدر حكم بحقه قبل عام في محكمه كوبلنز
يعني مدينه اخرى في المانيا انور رسلان
كان ضابط مسؤول عن سجن متهم بتعذيب وقتل
عدد كبير من المعتقلين السوريين انذاك
ولكن هنا قالت القاضيه بانه هذا الحكم
انزل به مشدد لانه هو اطلق هذه القذيفه
على مجموعه من المد الذين كانوا يعانون من
الجوع كانوا ضعفاء وهو استغل هذا الضعف
واطلق عليهم يعني قذيفه ولم يتمكن عدد
منهم من الهرب او حتى من ان يحصلوا على
يعني الاستشفاء بسبب الحصار الذي كان قد
ضرب على هذا المخيم لذلك بالفعل الناشطون
المدني الحقوقيون هنا السوريون يعتبرونه
حكم يعني ثاني تاريخي مهم جدا ويعطيهم
دفعا لكي يستمروا في المحاكمات او في
القضايا الاخرى التي يجمعونها لانه هناك
محاكمه ثالثه ايضا تجري ما زالت جاريه بحق
متهم يدعى علاء في مدينه فرانكفيت على ما
اعتقد وهو ايضا متهم بانه هو كان طبيب في
مستشفى عسكري في سوريا ايام الحرب وهو
متهم ايضا بتعذيب وقتل معتقلين تحت
التعذيب هذه المحاكمه كما ذكرت ما زالت
جاري ولم يصدر فيها حكم بعد ولكن يعني هذه
المحاكمه يعني تعطيهم ابدا بالفعل يمكنهم
الاستمرار بجمع ادله ومحاوله ايضا جلب
متهمين اخرين امام المحاكم الالمانيه نعم
شكرا جزيلا لك اذا راغده بهنا مراسله
العربيه من بابل
اكدت سلطنه عمان ان اجوائها مفتوحه امام
جميع الناقلات الجويه التي تستوفي شروط
عبور الاجواء العمانيه وفي بيان قالت هيئه
الطيران المدني العمانيه ان القرار رجاء
التزاما ببنود معاهده شيكاغو عام 1944
وانفادا للمطالبات الدوليه بعدم التمييز
بين الطائرات المدنيه امام جميع دول منظمه
الطيران المدني الدولي المستوفيه لشروط
عبور الاجواء العمانيه
التعليم قضيه معاناه للعديد من الدول
الاسلاميه الامر الذي دفع رابطه العالم
الاسلامي لتطوير العمليه التعليميه في 29
دوله تستهدف برامج الرابطه اكثر من نصف
مليون طالب
عشرات المبادرات والبرامج التعليميه في
دول مختلفه ومئات الالاف من الطلاب الذين
استفادوا منها بدءا من المراحل المبكره
وحتى العليا وفي كافه التخصصات العلميه
جميعها ضمن برامج الرعايه التعليميه التي
تعمل عليها رابطه العالم الاسلامي
للمساهمه في بناء اجيال المتعلمه في اشد
المجتمعات فقرا ووسط اقل امكانيات التعليم
لاحداث نقلات في حيات هؤلاء الطلاب
وتسليحهم بالعلم والمعرفه كما ان جهود
الرابطه لا تقتصر فقط على الطلاب
والطالبات بل تعمل عبر برامجها على تاهيل
المعلمين والمعلمات في هذه المجتمعات
لتحقيق استدامه تعليميه فخلال الفتره من
العام 2016 وحتى نهايه 2022 اقترب عدد
الطلاب والطالبات الذين استفادوا من فرص
التعليم التي توفرها الرابطه من 500
وسبعين الف طالب اضافه الى تاهيل
معلم في اكثر من 29 دوله كما عملت الرابطه
طوال هذه الاعوام على تقديم منح دراسيه
تجاوز عددها سبعه عشره منحه استفاد منها
اكثر من 360 الف طالب فيما قدمت 10 اعانات
دراسيه استفاد منها نحو 140 الف طالب وبين
المنح والاعانات التعليميه للطلاب في دول
عده عملت الرابطه ايضا على دعم ميزانيات
مجمعات ومعاهد وكليات تعليميه في دول عده
منها مجمع دار الحكمه في السنغال وكليه
الملك فيصل في تشاد وغيرها للمساهمه في
استمراريه العمليه التعليميه وتطوير مرافق
هذه المنشات
كشف وكيل وزاره الصناعه والثروه المعدنيه
السعوديه لتطوير الصناعي البدر فوده
للعربيه ان قيمه الاستثمارات الجديده خلال
العام الماضي تتجاوز 32 مليار ريال كما
اشار الى ان هناك اكثر من 1700 مصنع تحت
الانشاء
طوروا اللافت للقطاع الصناعي في السعوديه
خلال العام الماضي 2022
نحو 32 مليار ريال حجم الاستثمارات في
المصانع السعوديه بعد تضاعف اعداد
التراخيص
هذا التوسع في اعداد المصانع وفر 51 الف
وظيفه في كافه مجالات القطاع وحاول توفير
بيئه صناعيه امنه اتخذت اجراءات لحمايه
اكثر من 600 مصنع من المنافسه غير العادله
وتعزيزا للمحتوى المحلي شكلت وزاره
الصناعه والثروه المعدنيه فرقا في الجهات
الحكوميه
التطور والتوسع الصناعي في السعوديه لا
يتوقفان فبعد كل هذه الارقام هناك
1705 مصانع تحت الانشاء
رابع مستمره وفيها بعد قليل الازياء
التقليديه تزين احتفالات التاسيس في
السعوديه تساؤلات حول رحلتها عبر الاجيال
اهلا بكم من جديد احتفال السعوديون
والسعوديات بيوم التاسيس امس الاربعاء في
عدد من المواقع في مناطق مختلفه حيث شارك
الكثير منهم بارتداء الازياء التراثيه
التي تمتاز بتنوعها واختلافها بحسب كل
منطقه جغرافيه في المملكه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
زميل نايف الاحمري يعرفنا اكثر على تسميات
وجذور الملابس التقليديه في المناطق
السعوديه
الازياء جزء اصيل من هويه الدول والشعوب
وشاهدون على حضارات الامم عبر التاريخ
اختيار السعوديه مشاهدينا للثاني والعشرين
من فبراير يوما لتاسيس البلاد يعيدنا الى
تذكر الازياء التقليديه للمناطق الخمس في
المملكه والتي تدل على التنوع الثقافي
الذي تحظى به السعوديه البدايه من المنطقه
الوسطى حيث يشكل العقال والغتراب والدجله
واحيانا البشت والخنجر الزي التقليدي
لرجال الوسطى اما نساء نجد وما جاور نجد
فلباسهن التقليدي يتكون من البرقع والشيله
والعباءه او البشت وقد يضاف عليها الهامه
والحزام المذهبين في المنطقه الشماليه من
السعوديه عاده ما يلبس الرجال العجال
والشماغ اضافه الى الدقله بينما ترتدي
النساء الشماليات ما يسمى بالمحوثل رداء
باكمام طويله
المملكه الى جنوبها حيث يرتدي الرجال هناك
الصماده او العمامه كذلك ايضا الجبه
والمحزم والخنجر النساء في جنوب السعوديه
يتميز برداء تقليدي يشمل الشيله والسدر
ايضا نذهب الى شرق البلاد والتي لا يختلف
لباس رجالها التقليدي عن بقيه المناطق
المكون من العقال والغترب والبشت ايضا اما
نساء وفتيات الشرقيه فيرتدين غالبا لباسا
تقليديا يسمى النشل فضلا كذلك ايضا عن
الشيله اخيرا المنطقه الغربيه حيث يشكل
السداري عنصرا مميزا للباس الرجال
التقليدي للرجال غرب المملكه بالاضافه
للعقال والثوب ايضا كذلك والشمام فيما
يعرف المسدح بانه الرداء التقليدي للاناث
في المنطقه الغربيه من السعوديه هذا
التنوع الكبير مشاهدينا في الازياء
تنوع الثقافات الذي تحظى به السعوديه منذ
ثلاثه قرون وتسعى للحفاظ عليه مستقبلا
وتنضم الينا من الرياض خبيره التراث
واستاذه الازياء والمنسوجات التقليديه
الدكتوره ليلى البسام اهلا بك معنا دكتوره
ليلى وكل سنه والمملكه العربيه السعوديه
بالبدايه بمناسبه يوم التاسيس بخير دكتوره
ليلى يعني امس بالاحتفالات احلى ما يعني
لفتني شخصيا هو الازياء القديمه الاصيله
اخبرينا عن رحله تطور الازياء السعوديه
التقليديه
مساء الخير وكل عام ووطنا بخير ان شاء
الله وامن وامان واستقرار بمناسبه التاسيس
ازياءنا التقليديه هي امتداد للازياء
الاسلاميه التي نشات على هذه الارض
[موسيقى]
فتطور
حاصل في جميع
الازمان والاماكن
وبالتالي فان ازياءنا تطورت عبر الازمنه
والقرون وهي
تتاثر بتاثر وتطور صناعه المنسوجات
والازياء
اللي حاصله في العالم كله هذا ينعكس على
تطور الازياء التقليديه في المملكه
اعتمدت الازياء التقليديه على استيراد
المنسوجات من دول العالم المشهوره بهذه
المنسوجات سواء من الصين او الهند او من
الدول العربيه القريبه من الجزيره العربيه
واللي كانت مشهوره بالمنسوجات مثل العراق
وبلاد الشام ومصر
واخذت ملابسنا التقليديه في مناطق المملكه
المختلفه
طابعها الخاص فيها
ونستطيع التعرف على كل منطقه من خلال الزي
سواء للرجل او المراه
ويتضح هذا التنوع بشده في المنطقه الغربيه
في عند قبائل الحجاز فهي منطقه
تميز ازيائها
نسائيه المراه من من اي قبيله بحيث انه
اذا شفنا الزي نستطيع ان نتعرف على
ان المراه من
يعني يمكن تمييز هذه الاختلافات يعني هل
من طريقه وضع الشيله هل من خلال التطريز
من خلال عوامل كثيره من اهمها طبعا
الزخرفه والتطريز كل امراه بالرغم القرب
الجغرافي لقبائل الحجاز الا ان كل امراه
تميزت باسلوبها الزخرفي لثوبها وهي اكثر
منطقه يمكن ما تاثرت بالعوامل الخارجيه
لانه نجد ان المناطق اللي موجوده على حدود
المملكه تاثرت بالبلدان المجاوره لها
والمناطق اللي موجوده على السواحل البحريه
تاثرت بالتجاره اللي جتها من الهند او من
غيرها من البلاد المجاوره فنجد المنطقه
الشرقيه تاثرت في دول الخليج وفي الهند
بينما
المنطقه الشماليه تاثرت ببلاد الشام
والعراق وسط الجزيره العربيه اكثر محافظه
على
ازياءه وله شخصيته المستقله وكذلك مثل ما
ذكرنا
الحجاز نجد من الاماكن اللي تاثرت
بالعوامل الخارجيه
اكثر شيء بلاد
الحرمين
الحجاج والمعتمرين واستقرارهم من شعوب
مختلفه استقروا في هذه المنطقه وكونوا
ظه
رت سواء بالاكل او باللبس مع بعضها البعض
وكونت ثقافه جديده لهذه الشعوب اللي
استقرت في المنطقه وصار لها شخصيتها كذلك
المميزه ماذا عن اللباس التراثي السعودي
للرجل يعني كم تطور ايضا
اللباس لباس الرجل كان لكل منطقه لبسها
المميز ولكن باتحاد المملكه
وبدخول الرجل للاعمال الحكوميه
اضطر انه
يلبس اللبس السعودي الموحد فظهر الرجل
بلبس سعودي
متشابه في جميع المناطق ولكن الرجل تميز
عن المراه بمحافظته على زي التقليدي فنجد
ان الرجل استمر في استخدام الزياده
التقليدي مهما طرا عليه من
تحديث وتجديد
دون ان يتوقف عن استخدامه بينما المراه مع
النهضه اللي حصلت في المملكه بعد اكتشاف
البترول وقدوم الاجانب للمنطقه
وسهوله السفر والاختلاط بالشعوب الاخرى
تغيرت ملابسها تماما وتركت الزي التقليدي
واتجهت للازياء الحديثه المستورده ولكن
خيره وجدنا عوده للتراث خاصه في المناسبات
الوطنيه وفي المناسبات الدينيه عادت
المراه لارتداء الثوب التقليدي وعاد
الاهتمام له
اكثر والان نجد الاهتمام اكثر واكثر
بتشجيع الجهات المسؤوله على ارتداء هذه
الازياء في المناسبات المهمه مثل ما نشوف
في اليوم الوطني في ذكرى تاسيس في مهرجان
الفروسيه
وغيرها من المنى
واوجد عند المواطنين حب عوده لهذا التراث
والتمسك به والبحث عنه يعني يجيني كثير
استفسارات من جهات مختلفه يحبون يتاكدون
هل هذا الزي صحيح يسالون عن ملابس منطقتهم
في الناس صار عندها
فضول واهتمام لمعرفه ملابسها اكثر واكثر
وصار عندها اهتمام انها تصحح المفاهيم
المغلوطه عن هذه الملابس وتلبس
يعني الالوان معروف بانه ازي السعودي
للمراه لونه اسود لون قاتم ولكن يعني
نشاهد انه في ازياء احيانا ملونه هل ذلك
يتعارض مع الهويه الاصيله
المفهوم هذا غلط ميه بالميه لانه فهم من
خلال العبائها العباءه هي اللي سوداء ولكن
ما تحت العباءه كان ملون بجميع الالوان
المراه النجديه كانت تحب الالوان
صارخه نوعا ما او
الزاهيه مثل الفوشيا والاخضر الفستقي
والاحمر العنابي والبرتقالي
كانت تحب انها تضيف التطريز بكثافه على
ملابسها كان فيه نوع من الثياب اسمه الثوب
المتبثه والمجرحه والمبدح كان يتميز بوجود
ثلاثه الوان مضافه من الحرير بشكل هندسي
تزين هذا النوع من الثياب بالاضافه
للتطريز
فعلا الثياب كانت ملونه وكانت بهيجه منطقه
الحجاز تختلف عن منطقه نجد حبهم للون
الابيض بينما نجد ان نجد تعتبر اللون
الابيض تشبه بالرجال لذلك سالتك دكتوره
ليلى لتصحيح هذه المعلومه والالوان شكرا
جزيلا لك اذا من الرياض خبيره التراث
واستاذه الازياء والمنسوجات التقليديه
الدكتوره ليلى البس
شكرا لك
ونبقى في اجواء يوم التاسيس حيث شهدت
منطقه جده التاريخيه توافدا لاعداد كبيره
من الزوار من مختلف الاعمار والجنسيات
وتستعرض المنطقه التاريخيه موروثا شعبيا
تاريخيا من خلال حارات المنطقه مظاهر
الحياه القديمه فضلا عن حضور المعارض
التفاعليه والندوات الثقافيه والعروض
المسرحيه ومن جده التاريخيه ينضم الينا
مراسل العربيه سلطان السلم اهلا بك معنا
سلطان يعني اجواء جميله من ورائك
الاحتفالات لا تزال مستمره دعنا في
الاجواء
اهلا وسهلا فيك وحياكم الله وكافه مشاهدي
قناه العربيه راح ناخذهم اليوم في جوله من
ضمن احتفالات يوم التاسيس هنا في جده
التاريخيه واول من يستقبل الزوار من
المواطنين والمقيمين هذه هي الخيول
العربيه
الاصيله في مقدمه استقبال زوار منطقه جده
التاريخيه منطقه جده التاريخيه لها
التاريخ كبير جدا ضمن مسيره تاسيس المملكه
العربيه السعوديه تحدثنا عن لمحه سريعه
سوف نسدها لكم خلال
الفتره خلال
الدقائق القادمه لكن قبل ذلك اريد ان
اسمعكم الترحيبه الخاصه باهالي محافظه جده
يا الف خطوه عزيزه والله المكان مكان ايه
البلد كلها نورت فيكم مرحبا بك يا سيدي
محلك ومطرحك شرف شكرا لك على هذه من ضمن
الترحيبات الاساسيه لاستقبال ضيوف او
المحتفلين بيوم التاسيس يعني دخل الملك
عبد العزيز رحمه الله عليه الملك المؤسس
الى جده في عام
1344 للهجره انضوت جده تحت حكم المؤسس
وطبعا شهدت بعد ذلك المنطقه وعاشا فيها
لمده سنتين واخذ لمده 10 سنوات تردد على
هذه المنطقه العامه اليوم احنا 1400
1444 نتحدث عن 100 عام هنالك طبعا فعاليات
كبيره شهدتها هذه المنطقه يوم امس واليوم
كذلك المنطقه التاريخيه مستمره بشكل كبير
من خلال وجود المتاحف والمعارض التي تحكي
سيره تاسيس المملكه منذ ثلاثه قرون من
خلال وجود معارض الصور وكذلك المتاح هذه
المنطقه نعم نعم يعني هذا هذه الاحتفالات
تتزامن مع اجازه يوم التاسيس الى اي مدى
ذلك ساهم بازدياد اعداد المحتفلين بهذا
المكان الذي تتواجد فيه في جده التاريخيه
بدون مبالغه شاهد في المنطقه التاريخيه
امس في يوم التاسيس اعداد كبيره جدا تصل
الى الالاف نتحدث الارقام كبيره حضرت الى
هذه المنطقه مواطنين ومقيمين وكذلك حضور
من جنسيات عالميه ومختلفه هذه المنطقه بكل
تاكيد الاجازه اليومين ساعدت المواطنين
والمقيمين وكافه العاملين في القطاع الخاص
والحكومي بالتواجد في هذه المنطقه
والاستمتاع بافعاليات يوم التاسيس بشكل
كبير اليوم هذه المنطقه تتنفس التاريخ بكل
تفاصيلها بمبانيها بمساجدها القديمه
بمتاحفها ومعاريضها وساحاتها القديمه
اليوم ياخذ تاخذ جده التاريخيه الزوار
المقيمين هنا المحتفلين بيوم التاسيس في
تجربه مختلفه ثريه تاريخيه بكافه تفاصيلها
الصغيره تحديدا من خلال الازياء وغيرها من
التفاصيل وكذلك الرواه الموجودين في كافه
مناطق المملكه في كافه منطقه شده تاريخيه
للاستمتاع بهذه التفاصيل وحكي تاريخ
المملكه بشكل تعالى بشكل كبير جدا تجربه
ممتعه انصح الزوار ان ياتوا يوم غدا كذلك
الاحتفال بيوم التاسيس نعم شكرا
العربيه
تنطلق في شرق السعوديه اليوم فعاليات
مهرجان الكتاب والقراء الاول وذلك في خمسه
مواقع مختلفه بتنظيم من هيئه الترجمه
والنشر ويحدث المهرجان الى جذب العامه
والمهتمين بالادب في المجالات والتخصصات
الادبيه والثقافيه كافه ومن الواجهه
البحريه في الخبر ينضم الينا مراسل العربي
عبد الرحمن العصيمي اهلا بك عبد الرحمن
معنا يعني ما ابرز فعاليات هذا المهرجان
الذي نشاهد يعني روادو بداوا يتوافادون من
وراءك
نعم اهلا راويه فعلا مهرجان الكتاب
والقراء الذي ياتي بصيغه مختلفه وفعاليات
متنوعه للغايه هذا المهرجان الذي سيكون
موجود في خمسه مواقع في المنطقه الشرقيه
هنا من حيث نحدثكم الواجهه البحريه في
الخبر ايضا الواجهه البحريه في الدمام
الوجه البحريه في القطيف بالاضافه الى
موقعين اخرين وهما اكسبو الظهران الذي
سيشهد معرضا للكتاب لمده تقريبا عشره ايام
بالاضافه الى مركز اثراء مركز الملك عبد
العزيز العالمي الثقافي الذي سيشهد ندوات
وايضا بعض المحاضرات طبعا سادع زميلي نصر
ياخذ لكم جوله في هذا المكان الذي يستعد
لاستقبال الزوار خلال الايام المقبله
اليوم سيشهد هذا الموقع حفل الانطلاق من
خلال العاب ناريه في الساعه الثامنه مساءا
تقريبا وحفله موسيقيه للمطربه اللبنانيه
ولا الجندي التي
بغناء الاغاني
الفصيحه بالاضافه الى الفنان اكرم مطر
وهناك ايضا حفلات موسيقيه مقبله في الايام
القادمه طبعا هناك ايضا كما نشاهد هنا
استوديو تلفزيوني تم تجهيزه لوسائل
الاعلام في حال استضافه اي شخصيه ثقافيه
خلال الفتره المقبله ايضا نشاهد امامنا
المسرح الرئيسي الذي سيشهد الحفلات
الموسيقيه خلال الايام المقبله وايضا
الليله الحفله موسيقيه الرئيسيه ايضا
نشاهد هناك معرضا فنيا وايضا هناك فعاليات
متنوعه ما يميز راويه هذا المهرجان حقيقه
هو الاسماء الادبيه والكتاب والروائيين
القادمين
لاستعراض انجازاتهم الادبيه لجمهور
المنطقه الشرقيه من خلال استقطاب اسماء
كبيره ابرزهم عبدو خال
استاذه امير المضحي هناك منذ القباني
وغيره من الاسماء المعروفه والشهيره في
العالم العربي
ستكون مع الجمهور ربما للاستفاده من خبرات
بصحيح هناك امسيه شعريه ستكون موجوده ايضا
هناك ندوات حوريه موجوده ايضا كما نشاهد
الان امامكم هؤلاء هم ممثلون
[موسيقى]
المسرح الشارع وهي مبادره جديده تقوم بها
وزاره الثقافه من خلال يتم عرض مسرحيات في
الشارع امام الجمهور مباشره دون الحاجه
الى مسرح نشاهد الملابس القديمه هذه
المسرحيات ستحمل
عناوين متنوعه يعني الليله في الساعه
الثامنه هناك مسرحيه اسمها كريم حاتم ايضا
هناك مسرحيات اخرى فروسيه عنتره هناك
مسرحيه جميل وبثينا مسرحيه عمر بن كلثوم
لتجهيز يعني تجسيد الشخصيات العربيه
الثقافيه سواء في العصر الجاهلي او ايضا
العهد الاسلامي نشاهد هناك استعدادات
كبيره وترتيبات متنو
لمحاوله نقل التجربه الثقافيه
للجمهور السعودي بطريقه مبتكره ومختلفه
وجديده شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الرحمن العصيمي
من الخبر من الواجهه البحريه تحديدا يعطيك
الف عافيه
تمكين مستمر للسيدات السعوديات في القطاع
الامني حيث شهدت الرياض قبل ايام تخريجه
279 مجنده تابعه للمديريه العامه للجوازات
[موسيقى]
عند اقتران القمر بجانب ثريا في اليوم
الخامس من الشهر الهجري ودلاله على بدايه
فصل الربيع التفاصيل في تقويم مع خالد
اسحاق
[موسيقى]
اجمل النجوم الثريا واجمل ما بالكون القمر
واذا اجتمع جمالين الجمال الكون يا القمر
مع جمال النجوم قال العامه القمر جارنا
ثريا فالمقارنه معناها الاجتماع فاذا وقع
القمر بجانب الثريا في اليوم الخامس من
الشهر الهجري فهذا اماره وعلامه على تفشي
وانتشار الربيع ولا يجتمع في هذا اليوم
الا مره واحده والعامه يقولون جراند خامس
ربيعا طامس
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
واهم الاقترانات سته اثنين شتوي الاقتران
الحادي عشر والتاسع واثنين الربيعي السابع
والخامس واثنين صيفي الثالث والاقتران
الاول والاقتران الخامس اخر الاقترانات
الربيعيه وسنستمتع بالربيع خلال شهرين
شعبان ورمضان بحول الله وخلال هذا
الاقتران يبدا شعاع الشمس بالاحترار هام
الفؤاد باعرابيه سكنت بيتا من القلب لم
تمدد له طنوبه كانها الشمس يعي كفقابضه
شعاعها ويراه الطرف
مغتربه
[موسيقى]
ختام رابعه الى العناو
ين عشيه الذكرى الاولى للحرب تجدد المعارك
في خرسون وموسكو تستبعد خيار التسويه
مشاريع لتطوير التعليم في 29 دوله اسلاميه
المستفيدون بالالاف طلابا ومعلمين ومنشات
الازياء التقليديه تزين احتفالات التاسيس
في السعوديه تساؤلات حول رحلتها عبر
الاجيال
وتخريج 279 جنديه سعوديه في المديريه
العامه للجوازات
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]